or some people are saying
maybe the u.s shouldn't have anything to
do with this russia ukraine conflict
like should we stay out of it what is a
what what what is our business funneling
billions of dollars
into ukraine
to give them weapons and training to
fight russia like why why not let russia
do what they do let them
let them take away we could we could do
that we could just say you know go ahead
and brutalize ukraine and
and uh
take it over
but then the whole world becomes less
stable
because
if we
are in a situation with in which any
country is free to just grab any part of
any country that they like or dominate
any country or invade any country or
attack any country
uh you've got lots of candidates
uh
war could break out everywhere
and it lead it gives a free hand
to
uh
leaders like putin to use taran and
in their own interests i mean they're
already carrying out assassinations all
over western europe
ignoring you know the sovereignty of
european countries they've they they
their suspicions they've carried out
assassinations in the u.s
they the only reason they don't do more
of that is because they
they are to some extent constrained
a peaceful world
and a world that
respects the rule of law
uh is an advantage
actually to everyone
i wonder if
the u.s didn't
put all those arms
into the ukraine if there would be
much of all this fighting and all this
death
if they if they weren't
sort of
preempted to fight back against russia
like what what would happen if we had
nothing to do with it would it be the
same outcome would there be all this
fighting are we not
is america not isn't it
is it not in our best interest
to
funnel all this money
into the ukraine and prop up our
military military industrial complex and
prop up our media
and and portray uh zielinski as this
hero this war hero
well uh
and put him in put him on the oscars not
that we did that but we're talk about
getting him
he may yet get an oscar
but the uh
support for a a
a con
if if let's say
if we don't support ukraine
um
we're going to have a very difficult
time supporting those countries
that are in nato
and because uh although nato
by and large taken as a whole has a
strategic advantage over russia
russia does have the strategic advantage
of vis-a-vis the baltic republics
and
uh
they could overrun those republics very
quickly
uh and the baltic public could overrun
no no no the you know russia could
overrun the baltic republics okay that
you know ukraine has a population of 40
40 some odd million
estonia is one million
uh latvia is just a little bit more so
it would be no problem
they they could occupy them very quickly
as long if they lose their fear
if it and uh
having successfully taken over ukraine
without any resistance from the us and
any move to to support the ukrainian uh
resistance
uh
under those circumstances
russia could easily
intimidate the baltics it could
intimidate the countries of nato
and
they have they have they have
territorial claims in those countries
too by the way and
uh if
if they were to succeed then the nato
alliance would
would fall apart
and every country would make their own
deal with russia
and we would be faced with a situation
in europe
in which uh a country like russia which
is uh
run by people who are capable of
of taking of of
of seizing power by indiscriminately
murdering their own people
would be the dominant power in europe
and that would threaten american
security
because we would have you know with in
the absence of a lies
of reliable allies or in a world in
which those who are our former allies
were making deals
uh with a with an aggressive power like
russia
uh we would have very limited ability to
withstand them and we and we would have
have very limited ability to react to
their provocations
what if they were to what if they were
to decide to carry out terrorist acts
uh on the territory of the united states
under those conditions
our our our
advan our strategic goal
is to expand the sphere
of
security peace
and rule by law
to the greatest extent possible
and if we can't
prevent countries like russia
uh from behaving in in in barbarous uh
in a barbarous fashion at least you know
we can limit the damage and contain them
to some extent
do you think
that
first of all what do you think
putin the psychology of putin is after
all of these years
of
the us constantly trying to destabilize
creating nato basically essentially
surrounding russia
like
i mean we have what 14 nato 14 countries
are a part of nato up to the border of
russia
um
well who are those countries i mean
those are countries that were previously
dominated by russia
the baltic republics were part of the
soviet union
the
uh eastern european countries were
satellite countries that whose armies
were part of the warsaw pact
now so those countries know what it
means to be dominated by russia that's
why they wanted to be part of nato okay
not because they wanted to attack russia
but because they wanted to make sure
they wouldn't be dominated again in the
future
as they were in the past
that's the whole meaning i mean the uh
but aren't those countries essentially
influenced completely by the u.s
no they're not completely influenced by
the us but as members of nato they're
part of a defensive alliance
and in fact we you
we have
we have many instances in which there
are disagreements within that alliance
uh
particularly on the matter of defense
especially between the us and germany
but uh the us for example is opposed to
many name
nato countries getting their gas from
russia for partic for exactly this
reason that it weakens
uh our ability to contain russia right
but the those countries who suffered
under russian domination
and now eve and that includes nato
countries and non-nato countries like
ukraine and georgia
and moldova
they they they they were
concerned to become
members of nato not because they intend
to attack russia
but simply so that they would have
protection against being dominated in
the future the way they were dominated
in the past
now the you it's very interesting that
that russia has directed its
aggressivity against non-nato members
georgia and ukraine georgia was invaded
in 2008 ukraine was invaded in 2014.
the nato countries were not invaded but
but they could have been had they not
been part of nato
i mean estonia is not a match for russia
estonia has only a million people and
there are parts of estonia right on the
border with russia that are completely
russian-speaking and inhabited by ethnic
russians
now
those people
don't
necessarily want to be part of russia
but russia could always claim
that it's acting to defend them whether
they want to be defended or not right
whatever's convenient yeah
so that this this this whole explanation
that we were trying to destabilize
russia's or that there was some kind of
ill intent toward russia there was only
the intent to make sure that
countries uh that had been part of the
warsaw pact and had been part of the
soviet union could no longer be the
subject of various intrigues and
attempts at destabilization
they would have that that stability and
they would have of course uh the
uh
the reinforcement of of nato for the
democratic institutions
you